Hello everyone. I am Steve Kaufmann.
Today is a special video.
It's not the normal learn languages subject,
instead I'm going to tell you how I’m preparing to make a special video introducing my channel.
If you're interested in my channel, please subscribe.
The thing is, if you're going to study languages, for sure you're going to make mistakes.
It's not possible to not make mistakes.
It's not possible that there won't be times when you don't understand.
That's for certain. That's a predetermined condition of learning languages.
So I thought that in order to make
a trailer video to introduce my channel
so I decided that I would try to use 20 different languages to record this video.
The problem is it's not easy.
Every time I try to record the video,
every time I stop, I tend to move so the video isn't very good.
So I tried to speak in those 20 languages in one go
then of course I make mistakes.
The result is I have a video like this.
I’m getting get everyone to look at it. I would like to hear your opinions
is it worth using or not?
From one perspective the fact that there are mistakes is a good thing,
because I really can't speak those 20 languages all very fluently.
I speak some better than Chinese. Some are not at the same level as my Chinese.
Some of them while visiting the country I was able to use them.
Now it's not very easy for me I basically can't use them. If I want to recover my original level in that language,
I would have to practice and practice a lot. I don't have the time because now I want to study Arabic.
So the problem is right now you can look at this video
there are lots of places, if you know the language, you will notice there are lots of errors.
But should I show this video to let everyone see it and criticize?
Language learning is like this. You can't have a perfect appearance.
There will certainly be problems. Ok please have a look then let me know your opinion. Goodbye.
Language learning for me is very important it's quite an important part of my life.
Language learning is really not so difficult , what I think is important is the correct attitude.
In order to learn languages you have to have a good attitude, and you have also to know that the world has changed.
There's so much content on the Internet, there's so much technology, like MP3 players and AirPods, which help us.
Learning languages is a question of attitude. We have to enjoy the process of learning.
When I learned Swedish I read a lot on the history of Sweden by Hermann Lindqvist
But today there are so many things on the Internet and it's very important to read and listen a lot
and not to concentrate or worry too much about the details of grammar.
When we learn languages we have to enjoy it. You have to find things that you feel are interesting.
It's very important that you have a reason to learn the language.
It can be the literature, the history, friends, or the family. It’s very important that you have this positive attitude to learn.
When I learned Italian I listened a lot, books like I Promessi Sposi.
For me it was very interesting although for Italians perhaps it isn't so because it's a subject at school
but for me and i'm going to make mistakes and making mistakes it's part of language learning
Age is irrelevant. I started learning Russian when I was 60.
Ukrainian, I learned Ukrainian because for me Ukrainian history was very interesting.
Every language that I learn or have learned has brought me pleasure.
Korean, when I learn Korean A long time ago,
there was no good content so it was difficult for me
but today at YouTube and Netflix there are lots of good Korean dramas.
I studied Czech using wonderful programs from Czech radio, for example Toulky Ceskou Minolosti.
I said the same for Polish but I have not yet been to Poland.
I even studied Turkish for three months but I can't speak. One day I will.
I learned Greek before visiting Crete and Athens.
I learned Romanian before visiting the country.
Why do I study Arabic? Arabic is difficult.
There are many  local dialects: Levantine, Egyptian, Gulf, North African, but the culture and history are very interesting.
I may have forgotten a language or two.
I certainly don't speak them all equally well.
But every language that I have learned
even to a limited degree has been a tremendous source of pleasure.
And I think that we learn languages for our own reasons
and for fun. And if we are willing to put in the time,
and have a proper attitude and a good method we can all get there.
And that's what I talk about at my channel so please subscribe and join me.